Profesora Tamar Gendler: El día de hoy
tenemos dos temas básicos en la agenda.
El primero es terminar brevemente
nuestra discusión del castigo,
de la clase pasada.
El segundo es comenzar con la
tercera unidad del curso,
que es la unidad correspondiente no
a nuestra condición como
personas que tratan de cultivar una
especie de armonía interna,
ni nuestra condición como
personas en relaciones locales
de un tipo moral o
inmoral, sino más bien
con nuestra condición como
miembros de una comunidad.
Recordarán, de la
República de Platón,
el texto con el que comenzamos y con
el que terminaremos el curso,
que Platón percibe como un
paralelismo directo
entre la persona y la comunidad,
entre lo que se manda para el
alma armoniosa por un lado,
y lo que la comunidad requiere para
permanecer estable por el otro.
Uno de los temas tácitos que
subyacerán en nuestra discusión
en esta unidad final del curso
son las formas en las que el
paralelismo es manifiesto.
En cierta medida, nuestra
discusión del castigo
proporcionó un microcosmos
de la transición.
Recordarán que el la primera
clase sobre el castigo
observamos tres preguntas.
Tratamos de expresar en un
sentido bastante preciso
lo que quisimos decir con la
noción de castigo civil.
Y luego observamos dos familias de
justificación del castigo civil.
Una familia de teorías deontológicas u
orientadas en forma desierta:
teorías que observan lo
que alguien merece.
Por otro lado, observamos algunas
teorías consecuencialistas:
que tratan de justificar el castigo
con base en las consecuencias.
Y para cada una de estas
teorías, nos preguntamos
qué tan razonables son las
justificaciones de lo que ofrecen
y del tipo de conductas que
parecen ordenar.
Y aquí tuvimos el mismo
tipo de estructura
que encontramos en todo el curso.
Por un lado, una articulación de
un marco de principios
para entender un gran segmento
de la conducta humana
que trata de establecer las
reglas y principios de guía
por los que deberíamos
estructurar la conducta.
Y por el otro, tuvimos intuiciones
sobre casos particulares.
Y descubrimos que ahí, como
en otros lugares,
al menos para muchos de ustedes,
pero ciertamente para los
estudiantes en mi sección
y en las de los TF con los que he
hablado, había un reto en reconciliar,
por un lado, el marco filosófico que
parecía de verdad atractivo y,
por la otra, los factores
psicológicos que parecían
empujarnos
en una dirección u otra,
respecto de casos particulares.
Así, en nuestro análisis del
jueves, observamos que hubo
algunos intentos de proporcionar
exploraciones sistemáticas
de algunos de estos
fenómenos psicológicos:
factores que parecían exacerbar
el deseo de las personas
de infligir castigos, por lo menor en
la mayoría de las personas
y del tiempo, en la sociedad occidental.
Y factores que tienden a mitigarlo.
También hablamos un poco acerca de la
función de la suerte moral
como base de nuestras
respuestas al castigo.
A lo que quiero volver en la
primera parte de la clase de hoy
es la pregunta residual que tuvimos
en el contexto de nuestra
clase del castigo.
Es decir, observar la
pregunta de, por un lado,
cómo funciona el castigo
civil; y por la otra,
cómo funciona en un contexto
mucho más personal.
Así , recordarán que...
lo siento, parece que aún no tenemos la
versión final de las dispositivas.
Muy bien. Debió haber una
diapositiva aquí, que no es esta,
que unía nuestras teorías del castigo
con nuestra discusión en Alan Kazdin.
Lo que tenemos en su lugar es
una diapositiva antigua,
en la que yo sugería una conexión
entre el trabajo de Kazdin
por un lado, y la Ética Nicomaquea
de Aristóteles por el otro.
Recordarán que, cuando tratábamos
de pensar en la pregunta
de cómo cultivamos la virtud,
sugerí que uno de los lugares a buscar
en la cultura
contemporánea en la
pregunta
"¿cómo ayudamos a las
personas a convertirse
en lo que esperamos que sean?"
están en guías de paternidad
informadas científicamente
y llenas de compasión.
Creo que se trata de una pregunta
muy interesante a formular
con respecto del castigo.
Así, recordarán que la diapositiva
con cuatro tipos de justificaciones para
el castigo en la clase anterior,
tenía por un lado la teoría utilitaria
y por el otro la basada en el desierto.
Pero también teníamos, en la parte
de abajo de dicha diapositiva,
dos motivaciones para el castigo
que observaban por un lado a la
víctima y por el otro al victimario,
y de alguna forma buscaban
conciliar sus situaciones.
Y lo que sugerían esas
motivaciones para el castigo es
que,
con respecto a la víctima, lo que
importa es la restitución y,
con respecto del victimario, si de
verdad vemos hacia adelante,
lo que importa es la rehabilitación.
La pregunta es si esas
motivaciones son lo bastante
fuertes
y poderosas para captar lo que buscamos,
del castigo en un contexto civil.
Parece muy claro que esas
motivaciones están, al menos,
cerca de la suficiencia en un
contexto personal.
Y es con esa pregunta que el
análisis de Alan Kazdin,
en el contexto de esta codificación
de las prácticas culturales
en la guía de paternidad que leímos.
Así, Kazdin señala que si su meta es
algo parecido a la rehabilitación,
si la meta del castigo es lo que
sugieren las teorías prospectivistas,
que es el cambio de la conducta
futura por parte de la persona
que violó las normas
sociales de tal forma
que es posible pronosticar que se
conduzcan de forma pro-social;
entonces tiene una
increíble importancia
no meramente articular el tipo de
conducta que se desalienta,
sino también proporcionar
una articulación del tipo de
conducta que se desea.
"En vez", dice Kazdin, "de pensar
en la conducta de su hijo
en términos de lo que no quiere,
comience a pensar con base
en lo que quiere.
Cuando se deshace de una conducta
recompensando la opuesta,
los efectos de deshacerse
son más fuertes
y duran más que si se castiga
la conducta no deseada".
Y usted tuvo la oportunidad de pensar
en esta estructura de práctica
en el segmento inicial del curso.
La misma idea de enfocarse
en lo que es es que usted espera
cultivar como hábito en sí mismo,
y luego participar en
conductas que permitan
que ese tipo de prácticas se
vuelvan instintivas en usted,
fue una de las lecciones básicas de
la primera unidad del curso.
La mejor manera que
conocemos para construir
una conducta deseada es a través
de la práctica reforzada.
Kazdin va más allá diciendo, en
el contexto del castigo,
que éste enseña lo que
no hay que hacer.
Dice que la conducta
particular es inaceptable.
Pero una conducta es sólo una
entre una panoplia de
posibles modos de acción.
Y la simple eliminación de una
no garantiza que la
reemplazará algo prosocial.
Así, escribe en el contexto
específico de las luchas,
si usted castiga a su hijo por
pelear con su hermano,
ciertamente dejará de hacerlo.
No obstante, la próxima vez que
haya un contexto entre ellos,
la pelea estará en el repertorio de su
hija, el ajuste por defecto.
No ha hecho nada para cambiar eso.
Explicar en palabras que
la pelea es mala
tampoco cambiará el
estado de conductas.
Necesitarán desarrollar otra
forma de conducta.
Necesitarán promover el
opuesto positivo
para lograr integrar otra respuesta.
Ahora la pregunta es si existe alguna
posibilidad de generalizar
esta lección profundamente correcta
acerca de lo que uno hace
en las interacciones personales
a un contexto social?
Como señalé cuando leímos la
República de Platón,
comienza con la sugerencia
de que si quieren entender la
estructura del alma,
necesitarán entender la
estructura de la sociedad.
Y si quieren entender la
estructura de la sociedad,
necesitan entender la
estructura del alma.
En algunas formas, hacer la
pregunta aparentemente absurda de
"¿una guía de paternidad
tiene algo que enseñarnos
respecto del sistema de justicia penal?"
es hacer la pregunta fundamental de
la República de Platón.
¿Qué hacemos cuando participamos
en el intento más íntimo y personal
de cultivar conductas en los demás
que les permitan prosperar?
¿Pensar en ello les enseña
algo acerca de la forma
en que la sociedad debería estructurar
sus prácticas institucionales?
Kazdin da algunos
indicios de que piensa,
al menos de manera implícita,
sobre estas líneas.
Escribe: "el castigo puede
fracasar por muchas razones.
Una de ellas es que la
recompensa por portarse mal
muchas veces es más inmediata y
confiable que el castigo".
Y sigue adelante sugiriendo, no en
detalle sino como sugerencia,
que un vistazo a las
operaciones normales
del sistema de justicia penal
ponen esto en claro.
Si ustedes roban, reciben lo
robado de forma inmediata.
Por lo tanto, una recompensa inmediata
les refuerza la mala conducta en
un sentido muy social.
Si experimentan una
consecuencia punitiva
demorada,
ese castigo estará condenado al fracaso
como método de cambiar la conducta.
Lo que se requiere,
para que el castigo tenga un
efecto totalmente disuasorio,
es de alguna forma calcular que
el costo del castigo
entre en el momento de la práctica.
Kazdin escribe,
"uno debe eliminar el reforzador
inmediato de la conducta castigada,
si es posible, y eso es muy difícil".
Recordarán que hace tiempo
vimos una imagen de Ulises
tratando de alejarse de las sirenas.
Se trataba de una hermosa
imagen del siglo XIX,
de Ulises en un barco,
atado a un mástil,
con los remeros detrás de él,
con las orejas tapadas.
Era una diapositiva que
vimos en el contexto
de cómo superar la
tentación inmediata.
En nuestra discusión de Nozick
sobre los principios
y en la de Ariely sobre
aplazar las cosas hablamos
del tipo de estrategias que existen
para recalcular o recalibrar
nuestras evaluaciones de una
potencial recompensa inmediata.
Pensar en el castigo en su
sentido más amplio
nos da una forma de pensar en esa
pregunta desde otra dirección.
Como verán, ese tema volverá
a surgir muy pronto,
cuando comencemos a pensar en Hobbes.
Así, les dejaré este rompecabezas,
o acertijo de muchas partes,
como una pregunta.
El castigo nos iluminó, por un lado,
la distinción entre las teorías
morales utilitaria y deontológica.
Nos puso a pensar sobre la
relación simétrica o asimétrica
entre el elogio y la culpa.
Y nos dio otro medio para
pensar en la relación
entre lo personal y lo social.
Con eso, quiero pasar al tema
general de la clase de hoy.
Entonces, la pregunta fundamental de
la legitimidad política,
como ya saben por la breve lectura
que hicieron antes de Hobbes,
es la pregunta por qué siempre es
legítimo que esté allí
esa cosa llamada estado.
Un hecho sorprendente sobre la
existencia humana del siglo XXI,
de los aproximadamente siete mi
millones de personas
que viven en este planeta
en este momento,
casi todos ellos están sujetos
a reglas y reglamentos
que les impone un cuerpo
rector, el gobierno,
como consecuencia del solo
hecho de haber nacido
dentro de los confines de un
territorio en particular.
Vale la pena pensar un momento
acerca de por qué y quizá si
ese hecho es legítimo.
Esta pregunta, lo que hace
legítimo al estado, es
el que abordaremos en el contexto de
la unidad final de este curso.
Comencemos retrocediendo a un pasaje
justo antes del que nos concentramos
tanto en el inicio del término
de la República de Platón.
Así, recordarán que antes de la
discusión del anillo de Giges,
Glaucón relata lo que él
llama naturaleza
y los orígenes de la justicia.
Esto es lo que dice:
"Dicen que la injusticia es
naturaleza buena
y sufrir la injusticia es malo,
pero que lo malo de sufrirla
hasta ahora supera la bondad de
hacer lo que hicieron
y sufrieron y probaron la injusticia,
pero que carecen del poder
de evitar sufrirla,
decidan que es rentable llegar a
un acuerdo con cada uno
para no practicar ni
sufrir la injusticia.
Esta es la imagen.
Suponga que tenemos dos pastores.
Uno se roba los caballos del otro.
Por ello, obtiene un nivel de
placer de, digamos, 15.
Al mismo tiempo, aquél cuyos
caballos fueron robados
experimenta una insatisfacción,
primero de 15 por la
pérdida de los caballos,
y luego el desagrado adicional
de haber sido robado.
Así, regresa y se roba los
otros caballos...
lo siento, se suponía que esto
debía ser más animado.
Aquí vamos: sentir la presión de 15,
cuando el oponente siente
un desagrado de 25.
Así, la idea es que ambos reconocen
que es una situación en la
que robar es la norma,
ambos tienen el potencial
de terminar peor
que si ambos se hubieran quedado
con su propiedad original.
Como resultado, Glaucón sugiere,
que se reúnen y forman una especie
de acuerdo interpersonal.
Además, lo institucionalizan.
Como consecuencia, dice Glaucón,
"comienzan a hacer leyes y alianzas,
y llaman legítimo y justo a lo
que ordenan las leyes."
"Esto", dice Glaucón, "es el origen
y la esencia de la justicia.
En un punto medio entre lo
mejor y lo peor.
Lo mejor es hacer injusticias
sin pagar el castigo.
Lo peor es separarse sin poder vengarse.
La justicia es el punto medio
entre dos extremos".
Lo que tenemos en este texto de
2,000 años de antigüedad
es la articulación preliminar de lo
que ha llegado a conocerse
como la tradición del contrato social
en la filosofía política.
Esta es la visión de lo que es,
porque en cierto sentido
vivir en una sociedad
estructurada por leyes
es ventajoso para todos nosotros,
que el estado sea legítimo.
En esta imagen, lo que hace razonable
que siete mil millones de personas en
este planeta viven sus vidas
como consecuencia de haber nacido
en un lugar en particular,
bajo los auspicios de un
gobierno específico,
lo que lo hace legítimo es el
hecho de que como agregado
y de hecho como personas,
están mejores de lo que estarían si
no existiera la estructura.
Y ese es el argumento fundamental
que subyace en el texto
que leímos del Leviatán
de Thomas Hobbes.
Así, Hobbes, como saben por
haber leído el texto,
vivió más o menos en la misma
época que Shakespeare.
Vivió de 1588 a 1679.
Así, cuando nació,
se producían las primeras
obras de Shakespeare.
Y pueden ver...
lo siento, deberán estar cerca
del otro por un momento,
que llevan la misma vestimenta.
Mi animación está muy activa hoy.
Entonces, Hobbes era británico.
Es más conocido por su trabajo
en filosofía política,
pero también hizo trabajos en
lingüística y matemáticas.
Y es importante darse cuenta,
mientras reflexiona en las formas
en que el texto que leímos es
extraordinariamente sistemático,
que Hobbes estuvo muy influido por la
idea de que sería posible
derivar principios muy amplios
de la teoría política
de hechos muy básicos de la
psicología humana.
Y la idea era basar este razonamiento
en algo como el método geométrico,
cuando se comienzan con
axiomas muy sencillos,
se tienen algunas reglas de derivación,
y a partir de ellas puede construir
sistemas bastante elaborados.
En particular, Hobbes pensó
que sería posible
derivar la filosofía política del
pensamiento de la psicología,
derivar éste del
pensamiento fisiológico,
y derivar la fisiología del
pensamiento en física.
Los hechos sobre el mundo físico
limitaron acerca de la fisiología.
Éstos, a su vez, limitaron los
hechos acerca de la psicología.
Y luego estos últimos determinaron la
naturaleza de la teoría política.
Así, el texto que leímos
hoy trató sobre todo
de estas dos últimas etapas.
El texto que leímos es del Leviatán, el
libro que Hobbes publicó en 1651.
Y reproduje esta portada aquí
porque nosotros estamos sentados
aproximadamente a 100 metros de
esta primera edición.
Cuando di esta clase como un
seminario pequeño,
una de las cosas más
apasionantes que hicimos
fue un viaje de campo a la Biblioteca
Beinecke para verla personalmente.
Todos ustedes, como estudiantes de Yale,
tienen la libertad de caminar ahí y
hacer una cita para verlo.
Lo sorprendente de esta portada
son las imágenes visuales
en las partes superior e inferior.
Así, recuerden, a Hobbes le
preocupa dar una base filosófica
para justificar el estado secular.
Al final, lo que tiene es una
yuxtaposición de las herramientas
del estado secular con las de
la autoridad religiosa.
Habla de la relación entre el
castillo y la iglesia,
entre el poder de las armas y
el de la religión.
Lo que es relevante para
nuestro análisis
es esta increíble imagen de
la parte superior:
la del soberano compuesto por
cientos de personas,
cada uno de los cuales, en la
imagen de las cosas de Hobbes,
decidió racionalmente
renunciar a su derecho
a la auto-autoridad en ciertas cosas,
para garantizar la
estabilidad de la sociedad.
Así, hagámonos la pregunta:
¿cómo llegó Hobbes a esa conclusión?
¿Cuáles son las
preguntas fundamentales
que trata de responder?
Como dije, comienza con una
discusión simplemente
de lo que parece el razonamiento humano.
¿A qué se parece nuestro
sistema sensorial?
¿Cómo nos permite
comunicarnos el lenguaje?
Y comienza desde allí para hablar
de la psicología humana
y de la legitimidad del estado,
concluyendo con un análisis muy amplio
de la relación entre el estado
civil y la ley religiosa.
Las preguntas que hace son las mismas
que nosotros haremos en nuestras
próximas cuatro clases.
¿Qué hace legítimo al estado?
La respuesta de Hobbes es que
tener un estado civil,
una sociedad civil, es el
único medio eficaz
de lo que él llama
auto-preservación amplia.
Hablaré un poco de lo que eso equivale.
Una segunda pregunta,
¿qué podemos hacer para garantizar
la estabilidad del estado?
La respuesta, bastante
controvertida, de Hobbes,
es que solamente por medio
de la instalación
de algún tipo de soberano absoluto;
solamente al renunciar a cierta
cantidad de libertad personal,
se garantiza la existencia
continuada del estado.
¿Cuál es el argumento?
Comenzamos nuestra clase de hoy
con los increíblemente famosos
pasajes del Libro I, Capítulo 13,
del Leviatán, en donde Hobbes
expone el siguiente argumento.
Dice, con respecto de la posibilidad
de robarse la propiedad de otra persona
y potencialmente privar de la
vida a otra persona,
que los seres humanos son
relativamente iguales.
Son físicamente iguales en el
sentido de que cada uno de ellos
tiene la posibilidad viva de
matar y de ser muerto.
Y son mentalmente iguales,
intelectualmente iguales, en el
sentido
que los seres humanos en general son
capaces de usar la experiencia
para aprender a navegar por su entorno.
y en un argumento en
cierto modo evasivo,
sugiere que todos piensan de sí
mismos que son bastante listos,
y la mejor evidencia de la
igualdad aproximada
es que cada uno está
contento con su parte.
De aquí viene la primera premisa
del argumento de Hobbes,
que cuando tenemos este tipo
de igualdad básica
en fortaleza física e intelectual,
existe una "igualdad de esperanza
para alcanzar nuestros fines".
Todos pueden esperar de manera razonable
que buscar sus propios intereses no
será necesariamente algo inútil.
Sin embargo, hay conflicto de
intereses propios,
hablando en términos amplios:
quiero tomar todo lo que pueda,
y ustedes quieren tomar
todo lo que puedan:
Hobbes sugiere que el resultado
de esta igualdad amplia,
esta expectativa de la posibilidad de
alcanzar las propias metas,
junto con el hecho de que las
metas de este tipo
muchas veces suponen tomar
los bienes ajenos,
encontramos tres fuentes de
conflicto entre las personas.
Hobbes llama competencia al primero,
donde la meta que quiero es
obtener el control de las cosas
que ustedes controlan actualmente.
Noten que este uso del término
"sus cosas", en este punto,
es metafórico.
Muy bien.
No existe tal cosa, dice Hobbes,
como la propiedad en el
estado de la naturaleza.
Quiero controlar las cosas
que tú controlas.
Y la consecuencia de eso, dice Hobbes,
es que participaré en una
conducta violenta
para conseguir las cosas que
tienes ahora bajo tu control.
La segunda causa de conflicto en
el estado de la naturaleza
es la versión preventiva de esto.
El reconocimiento de que
quiero mantener el control
de las cosas que actualmente
controlo, con la acción resultante
de que podría atacar de
manera preventiva
para preservar mis posesiones.
Así, el primero es simplemente la
adquisición de objetos.
El segundo supone una
aplicación de la inteligencia;
un reconocimiento de que alguien
podría tratar de adquirir
las cosas que controlo y, a
fin de impedirlo,
debo actual de modo preventivo.
Y el tercero, dice Hobbes,
es esta característica psicológica
exclusiva de los seres humanos,
que nos recuerdan una vez más
de nuestra naturaleza
fundamentalmente social.
Y eso es a lo que Hobbes llama gloria.
El objetivo es la reputación.
Busco su admiración.
Y al hacerlo, tomo parte en actos
violentos para ganarme su respeto.
Hobbes piensa que, en el
estado de la naturaleza,
este tipo de conflicto es inevitable.
En particular, cuando se
suponen una igualdad amplia
y un auto-interés de deseos,
el resultado será la
guerra, dice Hobbes,
"de todos los hombres contra
todos los hombres".
No necesariamente una guerra caliente,
en el sentido de violencia
en todo momento,
sino un reconocimiento de
que cualquier momento
en el que pueda sentirme
seguro, se perderá.
Y sabemos, al vivir en una época en
que la amenaza terrorista
induce en muchos de nosotros un
sentido de miedo latente,
lo peligroso que es para la psiquis
el sentir que uno no puede estar
seguro en sus propios terrenos.
Es interesante que la amenaza de
que las cosas salen mal
tiene un efecto psicológico
casi igual de poderoso,
en anticipación de la actualidad
de las cosas que salen mal.
El resultado de esto, dice Hobbes,
es que no hay industria, ni
cultura, ni navegación.
Escribe en forma bastante poética:
"en tal condición, no hay
lugar para la industria,
porque el fruto de la misma es incierto.
En consecuencia, no hay cultura de la
tierra, no hay navegación
ni uso de mercancías que podrían
importarse por vía marítima,
no hay edificios amplios; no hay
instrumentos para mover
y remover cosas que requieren mucha
fuerza, no hay conocimiento
de la faz de la tierra, no hay
concepto del tiempo;
no hay artes, letras ni
sociedad y lo peor de todo,
el miedo continuo y el riesgo de
una muerte violenta."
Es importante pensar
cuántas características:
de hecho, todas las de su
vida cotidiana,
dependen de un supuesto de
cierto tipo de estabilidad,
de predecibilidad.
Sin ese tipo de estabilidad y
predecibilidad, dice Hobbes,
hay un miedo continuo y riesgo
de una muerte violenta.
La vida es, y esta es la cita más
famosa del Leviatán de Hobbes,
"solitaria, pobre,
desagradable, brutal y
corta".
Hobbes va más allá al sugerir que esta
imagen más bien desagradable
de las tendencia psicológicas humanas
que retrató en su famoso pasaje, es
uno bastante bien compartido.
Les pide creer que cuando
viajen, cierren las puertas
y cuando salgan de la biblioteca, que se
lleven consigo su computadora.
No habla de la computadora,
en esas palabras.
Pero al señalar la tendencia de
las personas de protegerse
con respecto de su propiedad y
su persona, preguntó,
"ya sea que no acuse tanto a la
humanidad con sus acciones",
dijo Hobbes, "como vivir de
acuerdo con sus palabras".
Así, ése es el inicio de un
argumento en favor del estado.
La igualdad básica, la tendencia a
querer lo que los demás quieren,
y el consecuente estado de guerra.
Hobbes retrocede por un momento
y luego hace dos
importantes advertencias:.
La primera es que señala que, a fin
de que su argumento funcione:
recuerden que su argumento
va a ser la razón
por la que es legítimo para siete
mil millones de personas
estar bajo el control
político de estados,
es porque si no lo estuvieran,
las cosas estarían peor.
Hobbes dice que el argumento funciona,
sin importar si el estado
de la naturaleza
es algo que haya pasado en realidad.
El argumento no se basa en
hechos históricos.
La pregunta, dice Hobbes, es el
estilo de vida que habría
si no hubiera un poder común
al cual tenerle miedo.
Y señala: y es lo primero
que señala allí.
Luego avanza para señalar que
la mayoría de las cosas
que consideramos implícitas
como parte de la
organización de nuestras
vidas
estaría ausente sin la existencia
de estructuras sociales.
Las nociones de justicia e
injusticia, dice Hobbes,
son nociones sociales.
Dependen de que haya reglas
que puedan violarse
y reglas que puedan hacerse cumplir.
Asimismo, exactamente en la
forma en que metí la pata
hace cuatro diapositivas, en el
estado de la naturaleza
no hay noción de propiedad o de
control legal como tal.
Lo único que hay es
posesión por la fuerza.
Ése es el nadir del
argumento de Hobbes.
De verdad son malas noticias.
Es solitaria, pobre,
desagradable, brutal y breve.
La pregunta ahora se convierte
en qué podría permitirnos
escapar de tal situación.
Hobbes sugiere, en la
conclusión del capítulo 13,
que existen tres tipos de motivaciones
que podrían ayudar a las personas a
salir de esta circunstancia.
Uno es el miedo natural a la muerte.
El segundo es un "deseo de
las cosas necesarias
para una vida cómoda".
Todos estos son los tipos de
cosas de las que hablamos.
Las cosas que vienen solamente
de posibilidades
predecibles de
cooperación:
edificios, aprendizaje,
comodidad, estabilidad.
Por último, dice Hobbes,
existe la esperanza,
la contraparte de la
esperanza de igualdad
con respecto del estado de
la naturaleza antes,
que "por el trabajo de uno",
sería posible obtener
las cosas necesarias para
lograr una vida cómoda
si solamente hubiera
circunstancias estables
para permitir que
persistieran los esfuerzos.
Ahora avancemos al argumento
fundamental de Hobbes,
que abarca, en los
extractos que leímos,
las derivaciones de lo que llama
la primera, segunda y tercera
leyes de la naturaleza.
Lo primero que quiero hacer
es presentarles la
terminología de Hobbes para
esto.
Luego les daré la primera, la segunda
y la tercera leyes de la naturaleza.
Con eso cerraremos la clase.
Hobbes habla de derechos por un lado
y de leyes por el otro.
Un derecho de la naturaleza, que
Hobbes considera fundamental,
y del que escucharemos de nuevo
cuando hagamos la lectura de Robert
Nozick el próximo jueves,
es la idea que se expresa en los
documentos de fundación
de la nación dentro de cuyos
límites ahora nos encontramos,
que todos los seres humanos son,
fundamentalmente libres en
algún profundo sentido.
Todos los seres humanos tienen derechos,
que Hobbes llama
explícitamente
inalienables,
para participar en lo que pueda
para auto-preservarse.
Ése es un supuesto fundamental de la
filosofía política occidental.
La Libertad, en la imagen de Hobbes, es
una noción bastante estrecha.
A lo único que se refiere es a la
falta de impedimentos externos.
Hobbes considera los contratos
que se celebran por miedo
siguen siendo vinculantes.
El tercer término que
necesitamos de Hobbes
para entender el resto del argumento
es la idea de la ley de la naturaleza.
Aquí es donde ocurre el truco en
el razonamiento de Hobbes.
Hobbes dice que si bien es verdad
que todos nosotros tenemos derechos
fundamentales a la libertad,
también es verdad que hay cosas
que nos son vinculantes
como resultado de la razón.
Existen reglas generales que la razón
puede llevarnos a reconocer,
que especifican lo que está prohibido
y lo que se requiere para
preservar la vida.
Y una vez que descubrimos
que este tipo de cosas es
necesario para preservar la vida,
se nos vuelve una obligación hacerlos.
Así, la idea de la ley de la naturaleza
es la idea que podemos
determinar que sería
y que nos permitiría
preservar nuestras vidas.
Y que entonces se vuelve
obligatorio para nosotros hacerlo.
Así, si se considera que un
derecho es un tipo de libertad,
una ley es un tipo de limitante.
Entonces, según Hobbes, ¿cuáles son
las leyes de la naturaleza?
La primera ley que deriva
es la siguiente.
Dice, como sabemos por el capítulo 13,
que la condición natural de
los seres humanos
es una guerra de todos contra todos.
Pero como sabemos por el
derecho de la naturaleza,
cada uno de nosotros puede
hacer lo que sea necesario
para preservarnos, y eso
incluye dañar a los demás.
El resultado de esto es la falta
de seguridad para todos.
Una vez que reconocemos
esto, dice Hobbes,
la razón nos dice que es una
regla general de la razón
que se nos exige "buscar la paz
si hay posibilidades de obtener la paz.
Si no, entrar en guerra".
Así, la primera ley de la naturaleza,
según Hobbes, tiene 2 cláusulas.
Tiene una cláusula de paz: la
cláusula del deber.
Si hay posibilidades de
cooperación, uno debe hacerlo:
buscar la paz y seguirla.
Y una cláusula de guerra,
que da permiso.
Si usted no puede tener una
garantía de paz, puede defenderse
por todos los medios que
tenemos para defendernos.
Ahora bien, la primera ley de la
naturaleza hace surgir un acertijo,
porque nos pide lo que habría que hacer
para tener la posibilidad
de obtener la paz.
La cláusula de paz
solamente entra en acción
si otras personas hacen lo
mismo que usted.
La segunda ley de la naturaleza expresa
cómo debe satisfacerse la
primera cláusula.
Hobbes dice que se
necesita estar dispuesto
a extender sus derechos
en la medida que otros estén
dispuestos a hacer lo mismo,
con el objetivo de promover
un estado pacífico.
Ustedes necesitan, dice Hobbes,
"contenerse con tanta
libertad contra los demás
como la que los demás
tienen contra ustedes".
Ahora bien, de lo que
hablaremos en la próxima clase
es un problema que surge de esta imagen.
Si los otros hombres no pueden
expresar sus derechos
tan bien como lo hace usted, no hay
razón para desviarlo de esto.
Porque hacer esto sería
exponerse a los depredadores,
"a lo que ningún hombre está
obligado", más que disponerse a la paz.
Eso es lo que dice la primera
ley de la naturaleza:
Miren, sin cooperación, sin
paz, la vida es miserable;
es solitaria,
desagradable, brutal y
breve;
de modo que su interés propio le
exige buscar la paz, si puede.
La segunda ley de la naturaleza le
dice: debe buscar la paz
en la medida que los demás
estén dispuestos a hacerlo.
Pero el problema que abordaremos
en la forma del dilema
del prisionero es que, sin algún
tipo de coordinación central,
siempre será racional para todos salir
de la situación de cooperación.
Esta es la luz de lo que Hobbes
da voz a esta solución.
La tercera ley de la naturaleza,
de acuerdo con Hobbes,
es que usted necesita
realizar sus alianzas.
Es decir, necesita cumplir
lo que promete.
Para hacerlo, necesita
tener la garantía
de que los demás también
cumplirán lo que prometieron.
Las alianzas, dice,
son inválidas si teme que la otra
parte también lo hará.
Así, para tener alianzas,
debe haber cumplimiento.
En particular, dice Hobbes,
debe haber algún tipo de
poder coercitivo
que obligue a los hombres por igual
a cumplir con sus pactos,
por el terror --les dije que el
castigo venía de regreso--
de algún castigo mayor al
beneficio que esperan
por violar la alianza.
La solución de Hobbes es la siguiente:
Dice que los hombres, de manera natural,
aman la libertad y el
dominio sobre otros,
reconocen que el costo de esto
es la miserable condición de la guerra.
El único medio de salirse de esto
es mediante la introducción de una
limitación entre ellos,
en la forma de la mancomunidad.
Esto, porque no somos como las
hormigas y las abejas,
la cooperación no puede lograrse
sin esta limitación externa.
En conclusión, dice Hobbes,
cada uno de nosotros debe decir, de
manera hipotética y voluntaria,
"autorizo y cedo mi derecho de
gobernarme a mí mismo
a este hombre o grupo de
hombres, a condición
de que tú también renuncies a
tu derecho frente a ellos
y autorices sus actos de
un modo similar."
Es decir, dice Hobbes, esto solamente es
cuando las personas conforman
una sociedad por la cual,
a cambio de ceder su libertad, es
posible vivir con comodidad.
Sólo entonces pueden volverse posibles
la mayoría de las cosas que damos
por definitivas de la sociedad
y la experiencia humanas.
Lo que veremos en la próxima clase
es un esquema de pensamiento
del dilema en el que Hobbes
cree que encontramos,
y preguntar si la solución de Hobbes,
la imposición de un soberano externo,
es ciertamente la única solución al
rompecabezas que nos formula
como su discusión acerca del
estado de la naturaleza,
y por último la tercera ley de ésta.
Los veo el jueves.